こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんかなりの
方はご存知だと思うんですけどもヒカキン
さんと僕がですね出前館さんの cm
キャラクターに就任いたしましてもう本当
に見れないことだねありがとうございます
もうほんと東京の音機とか横浜の役とかな
もうほんとヒカキンさんの僕の広告でも
溢れかえってしまってましてほんと日々
ヒカキンさんとねうれしいねって話をし
てるんですけども今日はその勢いで
ヒカキンさんとお祝いパーティを章という
ことで僕のを打つにヒカキンさんをお呼び
してでバエかでたっくさんご飯を飛びまし
て一緒にお祝いパーティーをするんです
けど
もうするんですけどもそんな帰ったよわれ
ないぞと普通にか気になったバキアイウと
話すんですけども最後にある程度はの食事
が進んでパーティーを終盤の最後らへんに
もう
祝ほど服を税制で見たことはないぐらいの
大きさの100人前の100人前のケーキ
を準備したのでそれをさえをサプライズで
ヒカキンさんに好盤とそれを食べましょう
って私でビックリさせてあげたいと思い
ますいや多分ヒカキンさん more
notes は見たことないと思うんです
外ビビると思います多分赤城さんが超巨大
なケーキを見てどう反応するのか楽しんで
いきましょうではん
[音楽]
話しました
役立てるですスプーン naro いう中
どうも変ですねじゃあねそうですだけで
親分さんに山に遊びに行ってきます
ありがとうございます
くださいいやいいやまでも混在ますかな
出前館でも朝からバッチ罰飛ばせて
いただきました
くって前から安全前から出れば違反で前句
すごかったよね街中ね3日前ぐらいかな上
ツイートしだもんですねあんまり駅行く
機会なくてもう嫌でもせっかくだから絶対
見たほうがいいなと思っていたんですけど
もう
ほんのねーぞてくれ
こんなことないなとおっ
メンチツイッターでコーンの cm 見
ましたなんかもういろんな県でもみました
ん
山ほど来てる情勢に本当にありがとう
ございまして枚かな
今日は何前ないですねハーティ量ですけど
機は何もないですなんですから激辛ソース
が入ってんじゃねーやそんな気じゃねーか
分からない
[音楽]
ブーブー色
サティロス
にょ若干ねちょっとヘルシーなものを盗ん
を得られず
ここらへんは全部僕が枯れます
グーッとスタッフとかが2つも食べていい
んだ佐藤ございますぱそう
[音楽]
今日は大丈夫場所バックも食べてくれるよ
ね食べてくださいといけません
プッ
というわけでさっそく食べていきましょう
かハイ及ぶ本当にではイカも釣れそうです
お猿スライバーいいただきまーすじゃく
ない私いろいろ今ねなんかね何か仕掛けて
んじゃねーか学校異例思ったけど出前館
さんというやっぱり料理ですからそういう
ことしないってかねぇ
それは家てこないと思うよねいいよ見です
ねえっどこの何かヤバイことしようかな
ぽんぽんですけどダメだと思いますやっぱ
食品なんで探すライブ参戦して食べて
くださいも作れるわけだよ
ピューン
あっは
本来は大事ですけどやっぱ
8月知って託すみたいなオシャレなからけ
うんまぁを俺ハンバーガーいきますは
おいっ月
いただきますすごいっ
うわぁ幸せですな家でこんな食べられるな
んで
すごいよねああああ
noon 煽っちゃうっっ
というわけであります今日は大丈夫です
楽しく食べましたけどはいい
出前館と見せかけて自分で買ってきたやつ
ドっていう
違いますよちょっとホットナイフしてるん
です
ドッキリ当てるやつみたいになったけど
なんだろう
体験ドアの静岡東京のバターが技術最近は
ほんと半々ぐらい
うん東京の信者も全然なんかずん日して
ないとまた住めないんで
オープン新居足頭を話していましたやばい
じゃん僕言ってるじゃん
もう一と感じたのはラズましょうか日々の
疲れるよだった
カキコ食べるきっかけに山に
とうとう全然食べなかったら
4 pe
[音楽]
違いますねこれは今日は本当に味て
ください僕らも高さ約と
それは
これがあったらもうそれもさあ何か持って
帰って着るのはよ文句言ってんだよかぜひ
できるかこれは8分とされない来ていい
ですかマナーが悪い気抹茶
やっぱここあざぶとんでさぁだ言ったろ
ああございます
また使えない恋
今何か設定もないですよ
ua いい
んですよ
本当は強かっつの
通しましたまっさか私は現場させようとし
て部屋や ep よりれたことで楽しそう
に撮る若院さをこの案件
連中がやってろがそんなこと揃えねじゃあ
及ぶ
気づきました
えっ
英語冷房たいって誰だと思う
何もないですなんでデータビューのサーズ
バーター使った cad スタッフた
多かったねー
んじゃない手はない
ああもうことでもはですねうん
1節はいっぱい結構ないっぱいなんだけど
これもですよねやっぱこれ無理して食べて
もらうんだからとっといてまたチンしたり
揚げ物もあのねトースターとかで焼くと
美味しいじゃんむしろいいんじゃね ez
を超えましたねうん
結構食ったところなんですけど
小山食事といえば
おすすめ2
レーザーとめでとうすかっ
ねデザートだといけちゃうよねー音は良い
ですねちょっとデザートも別で僕ちょっと
作っといたんだ
作っておいたちょっと待ったらいいなと
思っておけばね毎晩チャンネルん
も手軽にごゆっくり保育いっ
[音楽]
ん
n
などデービッドああ
これ
ブードゥー君
[音楽]
7なぜ購読際お待ちでこれだけねーぞ予防
れこれ
を呼ぶおきましょう
4日
いやんだね形が一切れだろうにあっ
はっきり多分くれるだろうか
ラース隠れて小屋手前から本当に誰で
頑張ったということで義人にクソ d 返っ
ケーキ準備しましたーー
ありがとうございますああああああ
[音楽]
これやばくないか8倍でこれいつ100人
前ますえっマジでちゃう
これはやりすぎましたねはぁ
me
どうですかなく
やばい戦コレ出前館でもすでにまあ不不不
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
不不不不不不不不不不不不是て食べれない
んでカットしてちょっと切れずちょっと
だけ食べますよいいよなんですけどこんな
の綺麗じゃない普通のナイフとフォークだ
ティっ
はない
[音楽]
a
第二波が絶えないこと言いましたねええ
ええ
怖い怖い怖い怖い
a をまったりしこれ
えええ
いるしちゃううまくやって切ったとしても
覚めるようのフォークがまたないじゃない
か
詰まっているフォークもあるのかよ
ええええええ
くっていいかな僕もできました絶
使える応募しましたやばすぎじゃ
ベガスいいやんっ
食えねーよあっはいこれじゃあ買ってねっ
ねっ
ほんとあんのちょっと軽いんですよバーン
とかやっても
大分多い気もねえパパケーキももう詰んで
ねナイフとフォークを大きくしないとと
思ってもう売ってくれないとねこんなジャ
ズっ tg みろ best web 切り
まして返金言うとうっわー
[音楽]
これ何度みんなではわけないとそう
俺たちはこれなかなかありません
うわぁ
うはっはー
yeah
これ幸福で1月してますマジで言ってる
あっな中にもちょっとつけるか5両ねはい
もったいないから
ハッハッハー
はい
ねえ結婚式じゃんだよ結婚式でもないよ今
だろうなにこの道
うんと出前館のお祝いで
ありがとうござんす食べようと思ってたら
サプライズ定期が非常に大きいたと思いや
ナイフとフォークも大きいとっきりでした
あーやっぱたかった
俺もう何だろうなかなかなくてさぁ
すっごいさあよ
パティ
ウオッチャー横
旅費いただきます
yeah帰っとばいい
うーんうめえ
1度目来年も頑張らなあかんなあとね
ほんとにこんないいもん食って
ブーブー頑張って言って後列のが入っ
サターンのを塗って言っていっ
こりゃあ
一人ルくんははいというわけで及ぶと的で
会の昆布るんですけどこの際ずつさせるに
僕らだと食べきれないのでその今日
いろんなさせたもいらっしゃいますので
みんなでおいしく食べたいと思うでしょ
入っていただい簿付のでさあ満腹です雨量
でこのシーンです
もう寝たいですんだっ
本当にも親分と外れ冊をでペロキャンディ
選んで頂いたりして本当に素敵な一年だっ
たのですとそうねもっと頑張っていき
ましょうが無敵じゃないでもそしてですね
ここからちょっと素晴らしいキャンペーン
がございますくすごいよなんとですね
ヒカキンさんと肇社長のかわいらしい人形
のセット100名様に pro現在とし
まーす
イゼットちょうだいもれますけどねこれも
れますがどれがもらえるかなぁたの cm
の葉っぱてる生きてるだろぬいぐるみあの
可愛いめっちゃ可愛いんですけどもなんと
100名様に当たるんですけども100
セットってことですねペットでそう日か
議員さんの肇社長のセット100名様に
プレゼントしますキャンペーン期間なん
ですけども11月の30日今日から10
日間按続きます1日ずう名ずつあたってて
全部で10日があるので100年になると
いうことでございますこれ毎日さまたね
ああああじゃああ
てぃひ*除菌皆さん概要欄に詳しい参加
方法いますのでぜひ参加してみてください
10カンちゃんはいそして当選された方の
ヒカキンさんはじめ社長の人形ですね2月
の上旬発送予定でございますお楽しみに
及ぶここからもすごいキャンペーンが
ございますよそうですね10日間限定で
初めて出前館を利用する方ず実質1塩で
食べます
2,001円以上の中央した方2000円
オフのクーポンが手に入ります
クーポンコード初めでございます枚から
始めさん森でこのクーポン神戸注文する
ときはアプリから注文すれば使えますので
ぜひ利用してみてくださいすごいですよ
ぐっ2001円
の方が1円抜けませんで鮮度もやばいでで
by かんでええええっ
絵本とかね初めての方是非俺様してみて
ください6しますというわけで今回も
すげーキャンペーンが2つあるんですけど
も詳しい内容は概要欄に術でありますので
ぜひチェックしてみてくださいウイグル
水戸空港というわけで我々も引き続きで前
から使っていきましょう頑張りましょう員
じゃんっグループは
[音楽]
bl